- Calling all cars. We
got a honey. Eight seven.
A Massachusetts' beekeeper
is facing felony assault
and battery charges after
she allegedly unleashed hell
on a group of local police officers
who were serving an eviction notice.
Hell in the form of bees
(bees swarming noises)
- My eyes! Ah!
- Rory Woods was one of several people
protesting the eviction of a local woman.
But before the police arrived,
Woods camped out at the
eviction site in an SUV,
towing several beehives.
When the police arrived,
Woods put on a beekeeper
suit and opened the cage.
A bee allegedly stung
an officer in the face
and when the officer said
he was allergic to bees,
Wood allegedly haunted him,
"Oh, you're allergic? Good."
Police said four officers
were stung by bees
and three of those officers were allergic.
A prosecutor charged Woods
with four counts of assault
and battery with a dangerous
weapon, and three counts
of assault with a dangerous
weapon and disorderly conduct.
These charges would net Woods
10 to 15 years in prison.
Now this would be a great law school hypo.
Bees are wild animals.
Is a big keeper even
responsible for their actions?
Yes, under these circumstances she is.
So be careful when you get
involved in a sting operation.